[Music]
maybe it's time Olivia
[Music]
[Applause]
it's time with you
[Music]
Dick's luck to change main pillar digs
let's try
you know man in the old days I always
knew like you were gonna do something
that you'd be alright it's the first
time I worried about you can I ask you a
personal question okay tell me something
good
do you write songs or anything I don't
sing my own songs
why I just don't feel comfortable why
won't you feel comfortable almost every
single person has told me they like the
way I sounded but that they didn't like
the way I look I think you're beautiful
Hey what I just want to take another
look at you you know the good times I
find myself
bull J isn't gonna do become sing that
song that I love I can't do that
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
therefore
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
tell me something boy buncha tired
trying to fill that void part do you
need mom ain't it hard keeping it's so
hard on the me that's he you just read
that now yeah pretty good
but in
[Music]
[Applause]
maybe it's down to the old
[Applause]
[Music]
I mean
[Music]
maybe it's terrible
it's just watching you've become a
musician it's just it's been a pleasure
I remember thinking you were always a
musician yeah that was like oh well all
I gotta do is tell you to practice I
work with Tim Manik there's an
incredible vocal coach we spent you know
months and months working on that voice
I think it lowered it like almost an
octave good yeah
[Music]
I had the sound in my head of what I
wanted Jackson's guitar to sound like
and it was heavily influenced by Neil
Young his guitars strumming never
floated around the neck it's hacked the
next three years ago Neil enlisted my
band promise of the real to be his
backing band it was the first time in my
life my eyes have gone from Neil Young
playing guitar to somebody else on stage
we were talking about so who are you
gonna cast as Jack's band and it was
like Who am I gonna kick no no real
musicians and it's gonna be problems
with real bats what's gonna be there is
no Jackson Mane without Lukas Nelson
I got those magnet own amps I'm that
1956 Gibson Les Paul Junior
and that became Jack sound I would have
liked a full day of prep and then at
like 2:00 in the morning meet these guys
at the studio and work till 4:00 and we
look like brothers at the try to look
like it was there to look like each
other
[Music]
remember we wanted to go super country
and then and then we thought well why
don't we go rock and roll yeah black
eyes was a song that I wrote while we
were filming I will never forget you
coming and being like I know what the
beginning of the movie is
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah I feel like we've done this before
the thing we do is so soon man come on
bro get up you know there's something
about when we started playing I always
knew like you were gonna do something
that you'd be alright it's the first
time I worried about you can I ask you a
personal question do you write songs or
anything
I don't sing my own songs why I just I
just don't feel comfortable I want you
feel comfortable well cuz it's like
almost every single person that I've
come in contact with in the music
industry has told me that my nose is too
big and that I won't make it
your nose is beautiful you showing me
your nose right now you'd have to show
they're looking at it all night oh come
on oh I'm gonna be thinking about your
nose we've always said I love truth yeah
your eyes should I touch your nose
oh my gosh let me just touch it for a
second
Oh feel like I'm done
[Music]
very lucky oh really yeah not really
that my nose has not made me lucky
tell me something boy
[Music]
punchy tired trying to feel that boy one
of the first things that Mark said to me
okay
I know you can write a pop song but what
do you absolutely have to write about we
were writing shallow from the point of
view of alley you know I had no idea was
gonna become part of the narrative and
then you start like seeing the opening
lines I really did get chills it becomes
part of the reason that they fall in
love
do you need a net hard keeping it's so
hard for the mean that's he he's right
there now yeah it's pretty good
there
there's no point in the movie where any
lyric is sung that isn't directly
related to exactly what their fear is
their hope their dream
[Applause]
[Music]
when I was writing music for the film I
had to think about Ali as if she wasn't
me
yeah you know you have so many sides and
it was evolving as the the film was
evolving in the shooting of this ya know
so I went with a sound for her even in
the pop realm that's unlike anything
I've ever put out before
[Music]